بعض تفاهمي حول التحالف الحكومي بين
اللقود وعتمه يهودي الذي ارسل اتمرن كثير
الى وزاره الامن الاسرائيليه تتوالى ردود
الافعال المحدره من مستقبل العلاقات
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه بسبب مواقفه
السياسيه المتشدده وزير الدفاع السابق في
بيان من مغبه
ستكون له صلاحيه وسعه
قومي تابع لوزاره الامن القومي سيكون
تشكيله جيشنا كبير في الضفه الغربيه
الخطوه من شانها ان تتسبب في اخطاء امنيه
خطيره
نيه الائتلاف المتبلول انتزاع صلاحيات من
بعض الوزارات ونقلها الى اخرى قد تؤدي الى
تفكيك الدوائر الحكوميه فلسطينيه قالت
حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس ان الاتفاق
بيننا وهو بين كبير سيؤدي الى تشكيل حكومه
اكثر تتطرفا وفاشيه اما جماعه الجهاد
الاسلامي فتوقعت مزيدا من التوتر السلطه
الفلسطينيه ادهنت بدورها التحالف الجديد
تنظروا وزاره الخارجيه بخطوره بالغه
مع اليمين المتطرف وممثلين الفاشيه
الاسرائيليه امثال كثير واتباعه خاصه
نتائجها الكارثيه المحتمله على ساحه
الصراع وما تبقى من علاقه بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني
الوزاره المسؤوله عن تطوير النقب والجليل
ووزاره التراث ومنصب نائب في وزاره
الاقتصاد وكذلك رئاسه لجنه الامن العام في
الكنيسات وقد سبق اندين عام 2007 بتحريض
العنصري ضد الفلسطينيين كما يعرف بقربه من
حركات صهيونيه متشدده